the Joe Rogan experience because you're
gonna be biased in favor of those
countries and in favor like look at what
happened with your mom could shogi and
Trump I mean they killed a journalist
they killed a journalist and they didn't
even get a slap on the wrist it was
nothing why again because we're so
intertwined with them with business
relations and he is making money from
them and and where is that right now
where's what Jamal Khashoggi think yes
as far as I know it's dead in the water
that's crazy
but this again look at the difference
between how they talk about stuff like
this when it's a US ally versus when
it's not a US ally when it's a US ally
like Saudi Arabia that does it there's
nothing to see here but you know if you
get a similar story coming out of Iran
for example who's not a US ally or
they'd love to go after Maduro and I'm
not saying he's a good guy but they go
after Maduro because he's not a US
allies they could harp away and all the
negative things about him but we're not
having a conversation about Jamal
khashoggi we're not having a
conversation about people being beheaded
in the public square for stuff like
sorcery Joe they kill people in Saudi
Arabia for sorcery and witchcraft and
drug smuggling and apostasy if you don't
think God is real and you say that in
Saudi Arabia they could kill you they
could cut your head off in the public
square and we're like killing people for
sorcery yes really yes they're killing
people for sorcery it's crazy
the khashoggi thing is super disturbing
because it seems like everybody's like
well what are you gonna do well what are
you gonna do I know I mean it would have
been cleaner if they just made him have
some sort of heart attack or an accident
or something along if there was
plausible deniability in any way the way
they did it it's almost like this guy
wanted them to do it a certain way he
wanted them to chop this guy up and put
him in bags and deliver him out of the
country in suitcases and [ __ ] or
whatever the [ __ ] they did however they
got rid of him you know yes it's such a
disturbing decision that they made yeah
and they know they're gonna get away
with it and again this is what happens
right it's been over a year they have
absolutely when was the murder how long
ago I want last time I was on the
podcast we spoke about it and last time
I was on the podcast was a year ago so
it was over a year ago it's just
whatever again if there are a lie that
means I mean they
really do there's so much business that
goes on between the US and Saudi Arabia
and the weapons deals and everything
that the argument Trump actually made
this argument in the White House sitting
next to you know the the Saudi Crown
Prince he's like they're buying so many
weapons it's so tremendous the weapon is
their bag and he holds up like the
pictures of this from Raytheon and this
is what he's getting this is from Boeing
this is what he's getting and it's like
oh my god imagine for a second it's
anybody like imagine it was a deal like
that with kim jeong-hoon he's like we're
sailing kim jeong-hoon these tremendous
with us today who I didn't see if Kim
Jong Yoon Jung hoon threatened us today
I think they I was waiting to show you
this oh my god Saudi Arabia's anti
witchcraft unit breaks another spell
what the unit established in 2009 is
charged with apprehending sorcerers and
reversing the detrimental effects of
their spells in the Gulf country let me
see the picture scroll up for the
picture oh my god that looks like
Baghdad Bob remember Baghdad Bob from
from the Iraq war where like when Iraq
was getting slaughtered he was like
everything's great
Iraq's kicking ass yes I do remember
that is like their Ministry of
propaganda guy yeah yeah like I might
shall I be the guy who they wanted to be
the was when the severed head of a wolf
wrapped in women's lingerie turned up
near the city of how do you say that
Kabuto I have no idea in northern in
northern Saudi Arabia this week
authorities knew they had another case
of rich witchcraft on their hands a
capital offense in the
ultra-conservative desert kingdom
[Applause]